[Music]
in controlling AF news controlling as
submitted by I love tiffin case oh you
[ __ ] I wrote it yeah you wrote it
yeah
mind you put Kate some tip yeah next
time next time next one we wave it wave
it is really should we rebrand yeah yeah
yeah wave you get way more brand knows
that way yeah we talked about this for a
long time no one ever saying that sound
point you know exactly and it sounds
like a [ __ ] show it sounds like a TBS
show that gets canceled no wonder we
don't give yeah it's like Rizzoli and
Isles or whatever you guys are [ __ ]
crazy
tipica sounds the best thank for its tip
on the case Oh
Ortiz skip on the case any day yes I
wouldn't watch that show yeah baby
alright intercept if a whole case of tip
is good it sounds expensive
I don't like the vacation I like a case
of tip cuz it sounds like he's not even
in the channel it's just a case of
Tiffany case if okay I like it I like it
I pictured a big box of wine TIFF TIFF
TIFF TIFF - oh I like that it doesn't
like that a man is jailed after he
banned his girlfriend from social media
only four weeks into the relationship so
he goes to jail for banning her social
media for weekend oh I hope it's not
like against the law to tell someone
don't sign on your Instagram or some
[ __ ] it wasn't just that you're like let
me check all your dams real quick did he
beat her ass you can go to jail it was
psychological abuse
so he they were together for less than a
month
when Matthew who's 24 years old
prohibited his girlfriend 19 year-old
Molly from posting selfies on snapchat
she couldn't swap messages with other
men on Facebook and Instagram and she
was not allowed to put kisses at the end
of her social media posts it's those
kids in general he would I know he would
also regularly check I got to put those
[ __ ] lips there for me he would also
check her phone regularly and he would
demand oh he would tell her what to wear
demand for her to send him pictures to
prove where she was a ho like Jesus
Christ what are you telling her to wear
[ __ ] stuff the guy he's these guys I
hate you should cover up it's like what
the [ __ ] dude I don't understand those
guys I don't either
I only understand it when like the girl
loves dressing like a ho and it's like
my mom you know it's my mom's birthday
you ain't gotta wear a [ __ ] bookie to
my mom's birthday you know see I'm even
cool with having fun I'm a degenerate
dude what depends right yeah not sure
like if it's like a mom having a
birthday in Las Vegas or whatever but
like if it's if it's a funeral like you
know you don't want Nicki going there
looking like what the booty hangs pants
at the funeral good some good going
there looking like a french maid like in
a porno and [ __ ] or they just look like
a waitress and I love that anyway that's
like you're wearing Dickies in the black
shirt I love that six years serial
killer wardrobe yeah you know I'm saying
like when you watch a circular movie or
like a scary movie and the any horror
movie the lead chick always wearing
tight jeans tight top like with boobs
chilling yeah absolutely that's how guys
want to dress women yep
we don't give up we don't give out your
cool jazz dude hear all your cool dress
oh you got it
Chinese Laundry or wherever you got it
I'm glad you're doing it they can't see
his head
Oh anyway yeah you're right good point
thank you how do you know Chinese
Laundry that's pretty good I know that I
know this up GOI did you do the laundry
at home I bet you guys I seem like that
kind of guy like you iron Nicky's
underwear and [ __ ] I fold them very neat
and if she fold them I said no no I stop
if guys dressed their girlfriends and
everything it would just look like
Halloween ho costumes every day be great
yeah that's really true no you could
address me like a ho women al oh yeah no
I think it's in public race public it
would be the the horror movie lead chick
wears just tight jeans and then like a
white tank top or some best and she
looks so scared I love that I love that
all right you like to help me look do
you like that I got I got out of the
under control no he likes the look you
migrate roll the dice they're [ __ ]
creepy little Asian dude he crawled
underneath her feet under the covers
feels like a [ __ ] bug crawling across
her he's like oh he's here can we play
tarantula on the feet again all right so
yeah this dude apparently the girl she
tried to break up with her boyfriend
multiple times and he would threaten to
kill her and her family he would say
quote you'll get a car through your
front window and I'll stab you in the
neck you know what I'm capable of
oh my god I [ __ ] wish I'd encountered
these people I know oh my god yeah so
apparently like on the first date they
were fine but then every day after
they're like after that he would just
get more and more and more controlling
if I had a crazy boyfriend like this I
would just try to find a crazier
boyfriend to save me from this crazy
boyfriend but then that crazy your
boyfriend it's gonna be too crazy and I
got to find another crazy your boyfriend
movie yeah I've seen that movie great
pitch Joe good pitch Joe thank you good
job
what movies that I don't know I felt
like I feel that I plagiarized I've seen
that movie I know you wanted to see that
movie it hasn't it doesn't exist because
he pitched it so well oh all right
we gotta make it save it all right movie
don't copy it they already said please
don't copy please they already said it's
theirs
all right put the pencil down they can't
execute the way I pictured it this is
the controlling dude why did I pick he
was gonna look like this I knew it cuz
they're always like the [ __ ] puniest
loser looking good I don't think it was
ugly it's just your husband's right
there dude puny like you comparing to me
masculine right that's what beauty [ __ ]
no dude god damn out of a granite rock
dude that's you did you ever get how do
you ever like you ever see TIFF on the
laptop at night when she's like sourcing
this [ __ ] for Jay King is and you see
attractive the hot guys like yeah hop in
your life like [ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ]
he looks like a young Jake Gyllenhaal
like a little bit mixed with the guy
from [ __ ] what was that he's never
jealous really oh you wanted me she
wants me to be jealous I'm never choked
make her feel like the princess jealous
case you just said this guy's hot what
are you gonna say I'm gonna find that
guy I'm a Stan
he tried at least he tried he looks like
silly [ __ ] Murphy noon
Selena Murphy Cillian Murphy he's in
Lincoln he's basically only he's only in
Christopher Nolan the scary-looking guy
he just looks kind of like spider-man no
Tobey Maguire great explainer what about
the new one the one that was in the
Avengers [ __ ] this guy what's his
girlfriend look like oh I see why
what wait no I see I know no I see why
he's let me just as I get with her
record yep nah man immediately no no I
mean immediately from like the way she
dresses I can see why a beta
[ __ ] would think I see it would
be so scared he's so scared of losing
you know he's like oh my god she's so
revealing like oh my god belly oh my god
like there's so many guys that gotta
[ __ ] go after her threatening guys
for him in his head she's like the porn
star that's way out of his League yeah
yeah that's what's going on here yeah so
he was saying that she never objected to
him checking her photo because he would
call her first thing in the morning and
call her like constantly and so Hugh did
you you didn't dream Bobby why don't you
see you loved me last night when you
urine should respond
you said you - he's didn't say love you
- no she was saying that that he would
call her every day and the he would call
her to wake her up for work and that
they had a job that she had a personal
alarm clock and that she never said that
she shouldn't call she was always on her
phone that it didn't bother him at first
that she was of course at first
been at first cuz it was only what a
month it was still at first it ever went
past that in the first 30 minutes [ __ ]
yeah but anything true of course what is
that the first two you know what I mean
yeah that's [ __ ] ridiculous that
escalated my psychotic man that is
that's pretty crazy so in his head there
Mary didn't like the third day exactly
he's like I was inside you that's a big
deal so then the judge was just saying
that even though this was such a short
relationship that he just could quickly
became way too controlling and abusive
like psychologically abusive so for that
he was ordered to to pay compensation to
her block with her charge of 735 British
pounds Oh England then the laws are
different because over here just be like
a restraining order like stay away from
her all right what about the [ __ ]
threads dude yeah well yeah that's jail
time for the threats that this was
domestic abuse because he would belittle
her too and threatened her I don't know
if anything that's non-physical would be
would have actual physical consequences
over here is it domestic abuse if their
domestic abusing you back like with
words too so like let's say you had a
cuss fest right like everyone has
arguments and stuff but then like you
both calm each other same equal words
like beige [ __ ] or whatever right but
in court would that only mean that only
one side gets in domestic abuse trouble
or do they go you're both in trouble and
you both get fine I was hope I was
hoping get off her bucket back Steve
she's not even hitting the game is fun
it's fun because she cares that's all
the reason why it's funny to me yeah
I do care I know you do you're so sweet
I just to wrap this up and change the
subject
you know what's [ __ ] sad all right you
know what's [ __ ] sad when I was in
high school a lot of my female friends
would have this kind of shame and I
remember this was me like fifth or sixth
grade where you just super [ __ ]
sprung and you can't stop calling them
and you learn your lesson because you
have your chance and you lose the girl
by being too [ __ ] pushing yeah but
guys go violent that's crazy yeah in
high school yeah
[Music]